Germany has begun deploying more
soldiers to Lithuania as part of NATO's
move to boost defense of its eastern
borders Russia's invasion of Ukraine has
rattled nerves throughout the formerly
occupied Baltic states in Lithuania
which is a NATO member shares a 270
kilometer border with Russia and fears
Russian aggression if the war spreads
Beyond Ukraine DW's Canadian Baya has
more
rolling off the boat into NATO's most
vulnerable region staff sergeant Max
whose last name we've been asked not to
give is providing security for the
bundeswear's new forward command element
in Lithuania
it's the headquarters of a German combat
Brigade with up to 2 500 soldiers
Berlin is deploying to Lithuania to
bolster NATO's Eastern flank are a
direct reaction to Russia's war of
aggression against Ukraine Max is a
deputy squad leader on this armored
personnel carrier
part of one of Germany's armored
infantry brigades
I think it's important because we want
to protect what we have
protect our country
window and now that I've been in the
Army for some time I also want to fight
with my brothers in arms and keep my men
safe
soldiers are also here for Lithuania as
collective defense which is how NATO
calls it
Vilnius along with the other Baltic
states had been calling for more troops
and in June German Chancellor Olaf
Schwartz granted their request
an additional combat Brigade on top of
the 1 600 soldiers that are already
there
but there's a catch
out of the Convoy traveling down this
highway only the command element
comprised of around 50 soldiers will be
stationed here permanently
the bulk of the troops will remain in
Germany on high Readiness and can deploy
quickly on short notice
conus lithuania's second largest city is
only a half an hour's drive from the
base where German troops are stationed
people here are largely happy that more
soldiers are coming
it's excellent yeah it's security I feel
safer to be honest to know that German
Army came to Lithuania the most
important thing is that Russia doesn't
even think about taking any aggressive
steps towards NATO or Lithuania
to ensure that Max and his men are armed
with some of the most modern equipment
in the German military
they say they are well trained and ready
to go to war if they must
I think it's good that we're here
I think it's good that there's a show of
force along NATO's border
and you also see the reaction from the
locals it feels good it's the job I
signed up to do and that's why I'm happy
to be here
after accompanying the brigades combat
headquarters to Lithuania Max and his
comrades will go back home
but not for long in October they will
return for their combat exercises with
the Lithuanian military